What advice would Jocko give his 17 year old self regarding school,
social relationships,
parents,
peer pressure,
et Cetera.
Yes.
This is like the actual Jocko podcast tonight is all these questions are about
Daca.
Actually,
that's kind of what I was asking,
like outside of the military,
you know,
if I was going to tell myself something,
here's a couple things,
know I would tell myself to detach.
I'll tell him,
tell him myself to learn that.
I would tell myself that that girl isn't the whole world and those friends
aren't the last fringe are ever going to have and the party isn't going to be
the best party of all time and all those things that you think it was just what
we talked about earlier.
All of those things that you think are a huge deal when you're young,
they're not a big deal and I know that's kind of messed up,
but it's true,
man.
It's true.
The things that you think are a big deal when you're 17 years old or not that
big of a deal and it's really hard to convince someone that's 17 years old of
that.
Right.
They also also,
what they don't recognize is things that are a big deal.
They don't recognize.
They think they're a little deal.
They're doing stupid things,
right.
Whether it's drinking and driving weather,
I mean,
kids still drink and drive now.
Like how dumb is that?
Seems community.
And so people don't think,
you know,
nowadays we've talked about social media already too,
but people post stuff on social media and you see,
man,
what is wrong with you?
And I guess,
you know,
I've heard now and you know,
we work with a lot of different companies.
When you apply for a job,
they go and look at your social media and see what kind of an idiot you might
be.
That's a good move.
But Oh,
it's a great move.
It's a great move.
So,
um,
yeah,
just,
just recognize that some of the little things are actually big and some of the
big things are actually little.
And I'd square those things away.
And the UNFI said this before,
when you're young,
you've got to realize that how you act now is directly related to your future
success,
to your future happiness,
to your future.
Financial situation to everything.
So it's hard to make that connection.
Right.
We were young and possible might be impossible.
Some kids get it though.
I'm telling you.
Some kids get it.
I think they're just,
no,
some kids get it.
Some of my oldest daughter's friends,
they get it like they're on track,
they're on track,
they're there.
They're like,
Hey,
I'm doing this.
I'm doing that.
They're on track.
They're 16 years old.
They're studying for the sats,
they're taking the AP classes.
My daughter included,
like they're on track to make stuff happen.
Yeah.
But I think,
and I'm nothing,
this is the case,
but this is probably the case one way or another.
That could be wrong.
I understand.
But okay,
so we talked about this before.
You know,
that part of your brain that understands all that that you're talking about
isn't either developed,
you know,
and this is from what I understand how you can influence people.
You just put them on a routine,
kind of like,
okay.
So it's the difference between understanding what I'm doing now and having a
tangible no.
Until I know where you're going with us.
And your,
I believe that there are definitely some kids like that that are just,
they're just like,
hey,
okay,
I'm supposed to get good grades.
I'm gonna could get grants.
I'm supposed to get there on that track.
I know for a fact kids that are like,
no,
I am going to do this,
this,
and it's gonna lead me here.
Actually,
you know what,
you're right cause this is good.
Blake,
you know,
remember Blake,
he used to do videos for yeah.
So he,
we did like a thing where it was,
I think he's like a Q and a or something,
something like that.
And he was,
he was talking about that were in elementary school.
He remembers feeling like if,
if I don't have perfect attendance and have perfect straight A's,
I won't pass this not passed,
but I won't like be the perfect guy or whatever.
And he said that he would,
um,
it would like create like this track to his whole future in his life would be
ruined.
That's how he felt was like,
Whoa,
no,
I'm living like literally minutes,
a minute and third grade.
It'd be like the reason I wanted to do my homework and get good grades,
it's so I wouldn't get in trouble straight,
straight.
It was not to get into college or none of that stuff for sure.
And then get some way.
Most kids are,
in my opinion,
most kids are,
hey,
I don't want to get in trouble.
Some immediate repercussions,
myself included,
hey,
I got a pass this so I can go to the next grade.
Yeah.
We all know what I mean stuff.
Or I don't want to be the guy in class who didn't do his homework,
you know,
kind of thing.
It was like it was,
but yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah,
I guess so that's,
that's me trying to,
I got to step outside of myself on that one.
And I guess the final thing,
obviously I'd tell myself discipline equals freedom,
which is basically what we're saying.
Yeah.
Get disciplined in how you live your life and that I think the biggest one there
is to,
whether they totally understand that or not.
Say like what you're doing right right now is the important things in life.
The things that you think are important or not are not important.
And then things that aren't,
that you think are not in [inaudible] are important.
So it's kind of like a,
like an iceberg,
you know,
I'll be old,
you know the people that are four knots over that little statement you don't
want because people really like the way you say important.
You just said it eight times.
Flurry of glory and rainbows.
Emojis.
All right,
well hey,
I agree with you.
So like the iceberg thing,
you know,
you know the iceberg metaphor where it's like people only see the top of the
iceberg,
but below that is like this huge iceberg.
So that's what,
that's what important things are in life,
right?
So you think it's just this little small little iceberg.
But when you think of the whole scope of life,
which you have no access to,
by the way,
as a kid,
it's that whole iceberg,
you know?
So if you're not focusing on that important part of the iceberg,
well I guess an iceberg situation,
it's not that important,
but another metaphor.
But it will sink your ship.
Yeah.
You know,
like in that kind of situation.
Um,
but,
and then at the same time,
the things that aren't really important,
meaning they don't have an iceberg under there.
They're just a little floaty things.
You think that's so important.
Nothing's going to melt or get coffee or whatever,
you know,
knock on a scent.
You know,
it's not going to think he's just trying to kind of,
it's a fleeting.